ce truc de bonjour bonjour on est au lac
des castors en droit emblématique à
Montréal un parc d'ailleurs qu'on va
agrandir c'est la COP cette semaine un
petit mot sur la coque est-ce que c'est
allé au-delà de vos espoirs est-ce que
vraiment on va c'est une bonne accord
qui peut changer les choses oui c'est un
bon accord qui va changer les choses de
protéger 30% des terres et des océans de
[Musique]
d'arrêter et de renverser la perte de la
biodiversité c'est des bonnes choses
c'est sûr qu'il y en a tellement plus à
faire mais mais de pouvoir avoir cet
accord là pour continuer de bâtir pour
protéger la nature que ça se fasse ici à
Montréal c'est une grosse chose est-ce
que le Canada donc vous vous engagez à
ce qu'il y a des marqueurs parce qu'en
2030 on vise 30% mais 2025 par exemple
est-ce que ça sera dans une loi puis
redémarreurs 25% par 2025 c'est notre
c'est notre notre cible aussi puis on va
y arriver on a on a passé 1% de nos
océans protéines nos comptes protégés en
2015 à presque 15% maintenant on va
faire le prochain 10% avec en
partenariat avec les peuples autochtones
dans les prochaines années on va faire
25 par 25 et 30 par 30 donc ça sera
enchâssis dans une loi
au fédéral 30 par 30 oui le 25 par 25
c'est un engagement qu'on a pris et on a
la piste pour arriver donc on va pouvoir
le faire d'ici 2025 2022 est-ce que ça a
été une année pour vous plus entre
guillemets facile ou moins difficile que
2021 compte tenu qu'on est sorti de la
pandémie en même temps il y a d'autres
gros défis qui sont arrivés c'est la
guerre
Ukraine sa venue la crise de l'inflation
globale les défis au niveau du coût de
la vie je trouve pas que 2022 a été plus
facile que 2021 et c'est on est en train
de vivre des années difficiles au cours
au cours des dernières années que ce
soit l'administration Trump puis les
menaces à l'ALENA que ce soit la
pandémie que ce soit maintenant la
guerre en Ukraine il y a un contexte
global qui nous causent énormément de
défis mais à chaque État on voit que les
Canadiens continuent d'être optimistes
d'être aussi fait d'être là les uns pour
les autres les Canadiens ont deux grands
sujets de préoccupation actuellement
c'est l'inflation vous l'avez dit c'est
la santé l'inflation est-ce que vous
vous sentez un peu responsable parce que
vous avez quand même distribué beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent la vérificatrice
générale vous a même fait part d'un
manque de rigueur entre 4 et 20
milliards d'argent que vous auriez pas
dû donner ce que j'avais pas contribué
un peu à l'inflation on a fait un choix
dans les moments de la pandémie on a dit
la meilleure chose à faire c'est de
s'assurer que les gens puissent rester
chez eux qu'ils arrêtent pas travailler
qui puissent se protéger les uns les
autres et on a fait les investissements
pour appuyer les familles pour appuyer
les entreprises pour appuyer tout le
monde et non seulement ça donnait des
meilleurs résultats au niveau de la
crise de la santé mais on est une
économie qui a reprises plus rapidement
que d'autres c'est sûr que c'était pas
garanti que ça laisse passer on savait
pas si on allait dans une récession une
dépression profonde pendant des années à
cause de la covid les gens ne savaient
pas on a choisi d'investir dans les gens
et ça fonctionnait pas seulement pour la
crise de la santé mais pour pour la
reprise économique mais l'expression
trop c'est comme pas assez est-ce comme
en est vous en avez pas fait trop la
vérificatrice je le répète vous dites
vos devoirs vous avez presque jeté de
l'argent par les fins il faut aller
récupérer ça et on est en train de faire
des suivis sur ce qui ont fraudé mais en
même temps
ça a été une situation sans précédent et
fait le choix c'est vrai que ce sera pas
été tous les gouvernements qui auraient
fait ce choix-là on a fait le choix
d'être là pour s'appuyer et ce que ça a
donné c'est pas juste que ça nous a aidé
pendant la pandémie avec cette crise là
mais la reprise économique a été plus
rapide et même la crise de d'inflation
mondiale qu'on est en train de vivre et
les moins forte au Canada que dans bien
des autres pays à cause de des avantages
qu'on a au niveau géographique mais
aussi au niveau du travail qu'on fait
les Canadiens donc oui il y a toujours
des il y aurait eu des choses à
améliorer dans la prochaine pandémie on
a appelé les leçons mais on espère
apprendre à voir et dans celle-là on a
fait les bonnes choses pour aider les
gens et ça donne des bons résultats on a
le meilleur
la meilleure situation fiscale de tous
nos alliés du G7 et de beaucoup de
rapports d'être PIB mais aussi le niveau
du déficit parlons d'argent monsieur
Trudeau il y a je lisais encore hier que
il y a des cancers qui ne peuvent pas
commencer leur traitement à temps il y a
des trop de liste d'attentes et c'est
partout au Canada au Québec notamment
les urgences et là les gens regardent
cette partie de ping-pong entre le
fédéral et les provinces à quand
vraiment vous allez de redonner de
l'argent en province et quelle expertise
vous avez vous pour réparer le système
je comprends tout à fait tout d'abord je
l'entends régulièrement de gens qui sont
inquiets pour la santé de leurs enfants
qui sont inquiets pour notre système qui
n'est pas là avec les hôpitaux les
docteurs les médecins les médecins les
infirmières on a besoin d'amélioration
des systèmes la réalité c'est que c'est
pas juste de l'argent de plus qui va
régler la situation ça va prendre une
transformation du système et c'est ça
les conversations que je suis en train
d'avoir avec monsieur Legault avec les
premiers ministres à travers le pays
parce qu'effectivement c'est pas le
fédéral qui a l'expertise pour dire ah
non ça prend quatre infirmières par
étage ou je sais pas trop quoi c'est pas
notre expertise c'est les provinces qui
vivent les systèmes de santé mais il y a
des choses qu'on peut faire pour aider
une partie c'est du financement
mystérieux bon vous demandez que
l'information soit circule au Canada que
les provinces vous envoie qui est très
bien pour qu'il nous le voient mais qui
partage de façon rigoureuse les données
de leur système pour qu'on puisse
comparer à travers le pays ils ont pas
déjà le cas précisément non
dans la pandémie c'est que au début on
avait aucune façon de comparer les cas
dans une province à une autre mais non
on a vu dans les manchettes que les
provinces
calculent différemment les taux
d'enfants qui qui sont en train de
souffrir c'est il y a des il y a une
main d'harmonisation à ce niveau là on
n'est pas en train de demander d'envoyer
l'information fédérale il y a des
inscrits par les provinces pour partager
des données si on arrivait tout d'abord
à se comparer à voir c'est quoi les
résultats et oui au Québec ils le font
mais à l'interne mais on peut pas le
Québec peut pas comparer ses chiffres à
une autre province parce que c'est pas
sur les mêmes bases et ça c'est un
impact direct dans la qualité de service
que les gens reçoivent donc vous dites
nous demandons un système de
communication des données une espèce de
transparence puis si on a ça on va
donner plus d'argent si on peut savoir
que les gens vont mesurer de la même
façon on sait que le système va
s'améliorer parce que les gens vont
demander pourquoi on a de moins bon
service ou de moins bons résultats dans
cette province-ci que dans l'autre on va
avoir on va voir des améliorations il y
a d'autres choses qu'on peut faire
directement qu'on est en train de
discuter avec les provinces mais on est
là pour aider mais vous comprenez c'est
comme si la maison brûlait puis là vous
vous dites ok avant d'éteindre le feu on
veut être
parce que vous comprenez que les gens ne
comprennent c'est urgenté c'est les gens
se disent est-ce que vraiment on bloque
une réforme ou de l'argent mais c'est
pas au fédéral de faire la réforme en
santé c'est au province de le faire nous
le seul outil qu'on a au fédéral c'est
de dire oui on va être là pour de
l'argent long terme parce que l'argent
court terme ils en ont même pas besoin
l'argent long terme oui ça leur
intéresse il nous intéresse de le donner
mais faut qu'on démontre du sérieux
d'améliorer et de transformer le système
et ça ça passe aussi par les données
mais vous savez très bien monsieur
Trudeau que la personne par exemple
monsieur Dubé je l'interview 40 fois par
année c'est pas vous qui avez des
questions difficiles sur la santé ce
sont les ministres de la santé des
provinces qui doivent à leur population
justifier les ratés donc c'est un peu
normal que le fédéral s'attache et de
d'envoyer de l'argent par transfert je
comprends mais c'est l'argent qui fait
des rêves ça vient pas de du néant ça
vient pas des nuages c'est de l'argent
des contribuables et si on va envoyer
l'argent que les gens payent au fédéral
pour améliorer les systèmes que les gens
reçoivent c'est normal qui est un
certain niveau de transparence des
conditions de la transparence et c'est
pas des conditions
d'une certaine façon oui on l'enverrait
pas si il y avait pas un niveau de
transparence et de l'intégrité des
données mais mais c'est dans un but de
d'améliorer le système vous aviez dit
monsieur Legault vous envoyez des
chèques à vos citoyens ça prouve que
vous avez de l'argent pour investir en
santé lui à vous est-ce que vous lui
avez redis ça à la rencontre on le sait
c'est pas une question d'argent dans le
court terme qui manque c'est de l'argent
long terme pour le système dans les
années à venir dans les décennies à
venir il y a des augmentations de coûts
le fédéral doit être là pour ça le
français
monsieur le goût vous demande le Québec
vous demande depuis un certain temps que
les entreprises à Chartres fédéral qui
sont sur le territoire québécois soit
assujetti à la Loi sans les banques etc
et donc une loi 101 resserrée un peu
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à dire oui à
ça nous au fédéral on respecte les
champs de compétences et les champs de
compétences qui disent que les banques
c'est de compétences fédérales je veux
pas que il doit provinciale régie des
institutions fédérales pas plus que
monsieur Legault voudrait que je m'y
mise dans un donc non mais je veux que
les entreprises au Québec soit
obligé soit encouragé soit encadrés pour
utiliser le français comme langue de
travail et donc dans la loi C13 on a mis
un dispositif qui va être semblable à la
loi qui est plus souple
mais l'avant que ça va aussi s'appliquer
dans les régions du Canada en dehors du
Québec ou une concentration du français
donc on veut les mêmes choses on veut
protéger le français mais on veut aussi
protéger les communautés linguistiques
minoritaires comment se porte le
français au Canada
il y a de la même réaction à faire on
est le premier gouvernement reconnaître
que non seulement le rôle d'un
gouvernement fédéral c'est de protéger
les deux langues officielles à travers
le pays mais c'est aussi
particulièrement de protéger le français
incluant le français au Québec on a un
rôle à jouer pour protéger le français
même là où dans la région où et elle est
majoritaire ce Trudeau beaucoup de
francophones ont été choqués de voir
le grand patron du SCRS devant la
commission rouleau monsieur Vignot
patron de chasr qui a Tidiane verset de
Montréal ici francophone bilingue bien
sûr
s'adresser uniquement en anglais à la
commission moi ça m'a fait penser à mes
années Ottawa comme chef de bureau ou
des fois on était mal de parler français
parce que
comment faire pour lutter contre ça mais
vous vous avez pas beaucoup parlé
français mal à la limite le contexte est
différent moi j'ai commencé mes
interventions en français au début quand
on va commencer à me poser des questions
en anglais oui j'ai répondu à des
questions en anglais mais oui j'ai été
déçu moi en tant que francophone de pas
voir plus de français dans cette
commission là et ça démontre encore que
il y a plus de travail à faire
l'immigration
dans cette perspective là vous comprenez
les craintes du gouvernement du Québec
de dire 112000 comme vous aviez suggéré
ou proposé j'ai pas proposé je peux
suggéré j'ai dit que la loi qui existe
les pouvoirs que le Québec a pourraient
accueillir sans besoin d'autres pouvoirs
plus de gens qui le font maintenant mais
je comprends aussi l'importance
d'accueillir de l'immigration
francophone et c'est à ce niveau là
qu'on est très ouvert à travailler
encore plus avec le gouvernement du
Québec
Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
ministre a dit qu'il y avait une entente
vous vous dites qu'il y a pas d'entendre
ça s'en vient ça sent il y a des signaux
positifs mais je veux pas je veux pas
m'avancer avec les Américains est-ce que
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer si il y avait une entente un
jour ça voudrait dire que les gens vont
continuer à chemin vaccin où ils vont
être laissés aux États-Unis
pendant la pandémie on avait créé une
entente temporaire parce qu'on fermait
les frontières pour
pour que les gens passent au chemin
Roxane qui soit refoulés ça va être dans
cette même ligne là qu'on est en train
de travailler pour empêcher que les gens
passent de façon irrégulière mais il a
créé depuis le chemin à côté devienne un
nouveau chemin Roxane
de regarder ceci c'est c'est compliqué
mais on veut avoir un système
d'immigration qui reste rigoureux mais
qui reste généreux votre père en 73
avait fait un pardon une requalification
des sans-papiers au Canada monsieur
mallounet le fait aussi il y a sur votre
bureau je crois une proposition qui
s'adresse à 500 000 personnes sans
papiers au Canada qui osent pas sortir
de l'onde parfois est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à faire ça on est en train de
regarder différentes choses qu'on
pourrait faire et ça ça fait partie des
choses qu'on est en train de regarder
d'un oeil favorable vous pourriez une
partie de votre collègue c'est pas par
rapport à ça c'est par rapport à la
crise de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre le
besoin de de régulariser des gens qui
sont ici depuis longtemps oui un désir
de faire ça mais il faut le faire de la
bonne façon est-ce que politiquement
c'est pas dangereux c'est ça qui vous
fait hésiter le message que ça envoie de
dire on va régulariser 500 000 personnes
je pense que tout le monde comprend que
l'immigration est une source de
croissance économique de d'opportunités
pour nos entreprises de richesse pour la
communauté et vino nos villes nos
villages on va continuer d'y croire mais
les gens doivent comprendre qu'on a un
système rigoureux qui ou les gens
suivent les règles en même temps très
bien monsieur Trudeau on va aller dehors
si vous le permettez de parler d'avenir
un peu un mot sur la Chine aussi je vous
posez des questions parce que je boucle
la boucle à la coque à Montréal à une
impression que le Canada et la Chine au
mieux travaillé ensemble il y a des
moments où on peut bien travailler
ensemble comme sur l'environnement il y
a d'autres moments au niveau de des
droits humains au niveau du commerce où
on va les mettre au défi on va même les
contester allons dehors
ce Trudeau on a l'impression que
l'arrivée de Monsieur poirievre vous
donne juste le goût de rester encore
plus
je suis rentré en politique pour faire
la plus grande différence possible puis
on voit malgré les grosses crises que ce
soit Trump que ce soit covid que ce soit
la Garonne on a pu faire de grandes
choses dans le pays on a pu avancer sur
la protection de l'environnement et les
investissements qui viennent avec pour
créer des emplois pour l'avenir on a pu
sortir plein de gens de la pauvreté les
millions de personnes la pauvreté on a
fait des grandes choses malgré tous les
défis et là arrive un parti conservateur
de droite pas à peu près qui veut nous
ramener en arrière de plein différentes
façons et on voit à quel point faut
continuer de lutter pour ces valeurs qui
nous rassemblent en tant que canadien ok
mais très bien mais d'un point de vue
plus personnel on a l'impression que
vous avez envie de faire cette bataille
là avec de sorte que ça envoie un
message dans votre partie je suis pas
parti là
je continue
mais entre le dire puis leur sentir dans
son ventre on a l'impression que vous
avez plus le goût que jamais de faire la
prochaine bataille électorale oui j'ai
beaucoup j'ai vraiment envie oui ça me
tente parce que c'est c'est c'est le
genre de pays qu'on va habiter dans
lequel nos enfants vont grandir qui est
en jeu il y a un contraste réel dans la
vision que j'ai et que je pense que je
partage avec énormément de gens et la
vision que présente ce parti
conservateur de de d'extrême droite de
temps en temps vous aimez la box il faut
quand même respecter son adversaire vous
le voyez c'est un combatif le bon là
l'élection partielle c'était moins bon
pour eux mais c'est un combat
il s'est pas présenté sur la terre
ça avait été Jean-Charles est-ce que
vous auriez du bon je peux m'en aller
c'est le parti conservateur que ce que
ce soit monsieur pollièvre ou monsieur
charrette ou d'autres
il a changé dans les dernières années
c'est plus les beaux vieux bleus de ma
journée
il y a un côté
dur et populiste qu'on retrouve des fois
mais les Canadiens eux n'ont pas changé
les Canadiens conservateurs c'est pas
automatiquement des gens d'extrême ou de
droite quand même en avance sur les
sondages en ce moment sur vous
mais vous êtes les Canadiens c'est une
bataille il va avoir une bataille
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de faire
peu importe quand vous quitterez vous
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qui vous
reste à faire Monsieur Tout défendre
pour pas clair pour moi c'est une
question de vraiment
[Musique]
établir clair clairement la direction
pour l'avenir de notre pays c'est
conservateurs veulent encore nous
ramener en arrière sur les changements
climatiques il doute que ce soit une
réalité ils veulent ils rouvrent les
débats sur les armes à feu sur
l'avortement sur plein d'enjeux qui pour
moi devrait déjà régler et je me dis
encore une fois que si on arrive à
démontrer que c'est pas ça le Canada
enfin
les conservateurs vont essayer ou les
gens vont essayer vont arrêter d'essayer
de nous ramener en arrière parce que
l'avenir quand je voyage à travers le
monde les gens regardent le canal du
monde dit mais vous avez tout vous avez
des ressources naturelles vous avez une
population croissante et diverses
vous avez les gens les mieux éduqué du
monde on a tous les avantages mais faut
pas les prendre pour acquis puis il faut
qu'on continue cette avancée là et
malheureusement ça risque vous êtes un
homme les ressources naturelles ça fait
aussi qu'on est un pays pétrolier vous
le savez projet puis c'est ça qui rend
un peu schizophrène notre pensée c'est
qu'on se veut on se veut la Suède un
pays mais en même temps on va chercher
du pétrole dans le sol on continue dans
de l'utiliser pendant que le monde est
encore en train d'utiliser mais au fur
et à mesure avec la guerre en Ukraine
l'Europe est en train d'écharmoniser de
façon plus rapide le Canada a des
solutions pour les gens et on a
justement que ce soit des concours que
ce soit à Sorel que ce soit à au
Saguenay il y a des solutions qui sont
en train de créer des emplois et de la
croissance bon pour tout le monde ce
Trudeau des petites questions avant de
vous laisser aller
votre père aura rapatrier la
Constitution
là on l'a mis sous une cloche de verre
on veut pas y toucher or
l'alberto fait une loi en disant nous
les lois fédérales s'appliqueront plus
sur notre territoire s'il faut ça se
cache one va avoir le la main mise
totale sur le gaz elle entre autres le
Québec vous a agacé l'utilisation de la
clause d'un obstant et l'Ontario l'a
utilisé bref ça va pas bien la
Fédération là est-ce qu'il est potant
alerte je veux dire le mot mais de
rouvrir la constitution de la moderniser
pour faire quoi au juste pour la mode
est-ce que moderniser je veux bien mais
mais c'est quoi le problème qu'on est en
train d'essayer de régler les province
se sentent pas bien et se sentent
obligés de faire des lois pour dire on
va contourner les lois fédérales si tout
allait bien ça c'est une question pour
les provinces et c'est une question qui
va se régler d'ailleurs dans l'élection
qui va se tenir en Alberta dans quelques
mois parce que Madame Smith ne fait pas
l'unanimité avec son approche moi ma
responsabilité c'est de m'assurer que on
respecte les droits des Canadiens quand
on utilise la clause des radiatoires on
est en train de suspendre les droits
fondamentaux des Canadiens pourquoi vous
demandez pas un avis à la Cour suprême
on est en train justement de de
s'assurer de faire les bonnes choses
pour pas donc un avis peut-être on est
en train de regarder différentes options
oui on va toujours être là pour défendre
vous dites les droits qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire vous pouvez peut-être avant
de vous retirer régler la question du
Québec pour régler ce sera jamais réglé
mais vous dites qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour moderniser la conscience ça
les droits autochtones enchâssé une
manière de de gouvernement de de mais il
y a déjà tout ça dans la Constitution
dans la section 35 il y a déjà des
reconnaissances utiles
on y touche plus et une constitution oui
il faut que ça le reste mais faut aussi
que si on va ouvrir circonstitution on
est des idées claires que c'est qu'on
est en train de régler comme problème et
pour l'instant le problème c'est pas
c'est pas qu'on peut pas trouver des
bons emplois pour les Canadiens c'est
pas qu'on n'est pas en train de livrer
la protection de la langue ou les
cultures tonnes sont arrivés à te faire
ça les problèmes c'est que il y a des
chicanes sur la constitution ben écoutez
si on veut régler des chicanes sur la
constitution en lançant une chicane sur
la construction c'est pas nécessairement
la bonne chose pour pour monsieur madame
tout le monde tensions mais ça se gère
globalement le fédéralisme va bien
écoute ça toujours été quelque chose à
travailler au jour le jour on peut
jamais prendre pour acquis mais oui on
arrive à livrer pour les citoyens à
travers le pays très bien quel genre de
vacances de Noël vacances en famille
vacances tranquille donc moi pas des
gros partez parce que là on peut
maintenant les gens on peut on va se
rassembler avec quelques amis mais
[Musique]
des moments de famille et vous souhaitez
croire en terminant pour 2023
que les Canadiens continuent de rester
confiant leur capacité de surmonter des
obstacles on est une année difficile et
on va dire les vrais choses 2023 va
commencer difficile il va avoir un
ralentissement mondial dans l'économie
on est bon pour s'y tenir on va rester
là les uns pour les autres le
gouvernement va être là pour aider de
façon ciblée ceux qui en ont plus besoin
mais il faut que les gens restent
solidaires les uns des autres joyeuses
fêtes à vous à toute votre famille merci